hello whoo I'm going to play and welcome
to this video playing fun to Z ok
against this guy I've got played six
games I've got two wins two losses two
drawers so someone will yeah it may read
Plato of course button somewhere maybe
pull ahead here in our encounters and so
Queens gambit accepted interesting line
should i played age six maybe I can
still do it maybe I should ok i think a
six is also often played not sure that
it makes much sense here to be honest
maybe just recreate I might take plane
I'd be fine might be five as may be a
reason why they go a sex all the time I
mean I playing this by ear so to say um
okay but that starts at not that big a
deal right if if it takes on d6 not
happy to give up my bishops but
remaining pieces look look okay d 55
it's not very attractive yeah i
admittedly
b5 weakens but at least I have some
temporary yeah initiative is a strong
word but can activate let's say yeah
just Roxy and also 94 it's a possibility
it's maybe not so bad I have reasonably
active pieces hmm ok but should be
forced that's helping him i'm in queens
III that's not a CH 5 that cannot be a
big deal
I'd see for maybe now I wonder if he can
sometimes just take one h6 it's a little
bit hard to believe but maybe maybe just
do this I mean I cannot believe that you
can take maybe this is some kind of
Perpetual if it takes but don't think it
can be worse for me if it takes I'm
going to take with the deep on if it
takes
it does okay Bishop age six takes Queen
takes Queen e6 should be fine I think
that's also interesting hmm yeah I
wonder I really wonder about that
possibility maybe maybe he really can do
that take them night coming to the five
would be would be nice is he threatening
anything maybe moving the Queen and go
for some kind of pin okay I'm going back
with that Bishop here yeah maybe you can
really take that takes takes Queen takes
I don't see a clear move tweeny six you
can check me and then have has light
discoveries
okay not very happy with this but should
be okay
if you move the Queen now I move my
bishop I don't see any great night
discoveries for him lady for maybe Oh
interesting move that's an interesting
but still where is he going with this
night don't see any good discovery
I just have something that queen of aid
to push his Queen back also 95 stings
and so on and it can like to be a good
position here 95 coming I still don't
see a good discovery 96 or stuff stuff
like that no I Knight takes e4 maybe if
I go queen of eight he's playing Bishop
before it's annoying definitely 94 for a
funky self pin me that's not so bad i
have f 6 in between g6 that's an
interesting idea try to play with the
long diagonal there good idea maybe
that's the good idea if you if you think
your moves I good idea this is the
typical case of famous last words is it
a good idea to test if this this plate
is hot or not and now it looks it looks
okay really does okay eight is a self
pin this one actually takes rook takes
that's very dangerous for white
time warning some 1992 with some kind of
move not sure how good it is but it's
interesting some other discoveries here
mehcad looks at least spectacular maybe
it shocks him whoops probably not didn't
see that move Wow shoot that you get
that's what you get for spectacular
chasm ah bloody murder I can just play
rook takes 96 is not I should have just
played normal stuff my position was
excellent let head that's that what's
how thats what happens if you place
something that looks cool
playing in such a weird way that are
actually still having some hopes him
check it smelling good idea to to go
there but anyway check check now I have
no time no bloody time on the clock one
believable how lucky can you be he's
blending everything away and reveals
time I have no time I have nine seconds
unless three seconds them with
everything yeah come on yeah and Abbott
okay I'm it's my own fault actually yeah
here I just have a good position with
normal moves and bam and they play some
fancy 92 after which he finds nie Dage
form just can do whatever this is this
also yeah like a sort of better check
this is what what the engine gives with
a clear advantage this is just bad my
bishop is like 10 times better than his
yeah and then Jaclyn he was completely
winning and plated in such a bad way but
yeah anyway it's not let's not go down
yeah complicated very complicated game I
think it looked a bit awkward but I
think I was okay always had active
enough
love pieces I took far too long for this
King age seven move like more than a
minute it was in young wasn't so
difficult and IM opposition against gets
really nice three is a good move i just
have to have to play the normal 95 and
not this fancy move yeah maybe at the
end i was too panicky with the Queen up
we'll just move move move okay i mean i
have three seconds which is really not a
lot of a check I'm up everything at this
point but yeah I basically have to have
to plan to promote them yeah bishop yeah
they are maids and so as of course of
course I'm the queen up but 32 seconds
it was tough to even pre move I was pre
moving Queenie for more always only four
but you can take and take everything
there okay thanks so much